hola a todos ahora que ya tenemos la
intuición de lo que es la divergencia y
lo que intenta representar trataremos de
darle una formula y lo primero que
quiero hacer es solo fijarnos en
funciones que solo tienen componentes
horizontal entonces estamos pensando que
nuestra segunda componente o la que está
descrita por la función q pues va a
valer en realidad 0 vamos a poner aquí
que vale 0
muy bien entonces un campo vectorial que
tiene su segundo componente 0 se
visualizaría más o menos así tendríamos
puras flechas horizontales verdad porque
no tiene componente vertical entonces
quizás apunta sí y luego puede apuntar
así o quizás apunta de esta forma sí y
luego tenemos una flecha grande en fin
el punto es que las flechas todas
apuntan en la dirección horizontal es
decir ya sea a la derecha oa la
izquierda así que pensemos cómo se vería
la divergencia de nuestro campo
vectorial b pero evaluada en algún punto
particular x allí
y de hecho pensemos cuando es que la
divergencia es positiva en este caso así
que pensemos en un punto digamos aquí
tenemos el punto x mayer y digamos que
aquí nuestra función p se anula es decir
no tenemos ningún punto
perdón ningún vector asociado entonces
para que la divergencia crezca como
vimos en un vídeo anterior pues
necesitamos que las flechas
por apunten en dirección contraria donde
se encuentra este punto verdad entonces
por ejemplo podríamos pensar en algo así
pero si pensamos en algo así quiere
decir que del lado izquierdo de nuestro
punto la función p tiene que ser
negativa para que esto apunte a la
izquierda y acá del lado derecho tiene
que ser positiva para que apunte hacia
la derecha verdad entonces podemos notar
aquí claramente que la función p va de
digamos de negativo a cero y luego a
positivo así que en resumen al movernos
en la dirección de x verdad que debe
crecer así que entonces la la
divergencia la divergencia de nuestro
campo vectorial sería positivo pero si
lo interpretamos de otra forma quiere
decir que la derivada parcial de p con
respecto de x tiene que ser positiva
verdad esto es para que podamos ir de
negativo a 0 y positivo es decir que la
función p vaya creciendo verdad ahora
bien si no tienes muy claro
nos referimos con esto pues tengo un
vídeo al respecto de las derivadas
parciales verdad así que puedes puedes
consultarlo pero espero que esto al
menos nos dé una idea de por qué la
derivada parcial de p con respecto de x
tiene que ser positiva pero bueno
recordemos que esta no es la única forma
que tenemos para plantear un escenario
en donde la divergencia sea positiva
verdad podríamos pensar por ejemplo en
algún punto digamos que este sea nuestro
punto x de verdad y que en este punto sí
tengamos una flecha asociada quiere
decir aquí que nuestra función p
tendría que ser positiva verdad pero
entonces para que ésta sea para que
tengamos una divergencia positiva quiere
decir que quizás lo que entra del lado
izquierdo tiene que ser mucho menor que
lo que sale verdad entonces quiere decir
que al movernos en la dirección de x
verdad nuestro vector va aumentando de
tamaño lo cual significa que el valor de
p también tiene que ir
lo cual vuelve a caer en el caso en
donde la derivada parcial de p con
respecto de x tiene que ser positiva
verdad y podríamos pensar también el
caso contrario en donde en lugar de que
apunte hacia la derecha en este punto
digamos que apunte hacia la izquierda y
entonces para para tener esta idea de
que se aleja más digamos nuestras
partículas de agua quiere decir que acá
tendrá que ser muy grande nuestro vector
pero en la dirección digamos hacia la
izquierda verdad en ese sentido y de
este otro lado tendrá que ser muy
pequeño quiere decir que va por ejemplo
para este caso aquí tendremos que el
valor de p es negativo pero a su
izquierda es mucho más negativo y quizás
a la derecha no es tan negativo como
como en el punto que nos interesa verdad
entonces otra vez iríamos de muy
negativo a poco negativo es decir la
función p va creciendo lo cual nos dice
que su derivada con respecto de x
positiva verdad así que lo que podríamos
esperar es que la derivada parcial de p
con respecto a x estará involucrada en
la fórmula de la divergencia de alguna
forma verdad justo en el punto xy y en
el próximo vídeo seguiré esta misma
línea de razonamiento para ver que debe
pasar con la componente vertical